perhaps as a historian
you may be able to appreciate this kind
of thing that's probably how you see the
world but
there's several ways to see a human
being like Vladimir Putin is an example
one is a political figure that's
currently
doing actions in the world geopolitics
internally the politics of Russia but
there's also that human being in a
historical context
and collecting information about that
person in the historical context is also
very valuable so you could see
interviews with Hitler
in uh 39 40 41 as being very bad and
detrimental
to all that is good in the world but at
the same time it's important to
understand that human mind how it uh how
power affects that mind how power
corrupts it how they see the world
absolutely absolutely I would be all in
favor and maybe he will if Vladimir
Putin would sit down with you absolutely
I I don't think you're boosting someone
like that when you ask them tough
questions in fact I think that's what we
need to do those sorts of figures tend
to insulate themselves some tough
questions so just to restate I I am for
the Lex Friedman interview of uh those
sorts of figures I am not for the puff
piece on Fox and Friends uh where they
just come on and they're asked oh isn't
it tell us what you think of this tell
us what you think of that yeah so but
there's a balance there because
a lot of people that interview somebody
like Vladimir Putin all they do is
hard-hitting questions they often
demonstrate a lack of knowledge of the
perspective of the Russian people and
the president there's not an empathy to
understand that this is a popularly
elected uh you can criticize that notion
but this is still the area that
represents the beliefs of a large number
of people and they have their own life
story they see the world they believe
they're doing good for the world and I
don't
um that idea
seems to not permeate the questions and
the thoughts that people say because
they're afraid of being attacked by the
people back home fellow journalists for
not being hard enough well maybe I think
that's probably true I think in my
experience with interviewers is that a
lot of them are really lazy you're not
which is why
can I just say okay this is not you
saying it can I just rant
if you're sitting across from Xi Jinping
from Vladimir Putin you you you should
be fired if you have not read like at
least several books on the guy the the
surprising lack of research that people
do leading up to it right so you need to
be a historian or a biographer you need
to be the kind of person that writes
biographies or histories before you sit
in front of the person not uh uh not a
low effort journalist and so surprising
to me that I think they're probably
really busy and it's probably not part
of the culture of the people that do
interviews to do deep deep like
investigative you need to be the kind of
person that lives that idea like see it
as a documentary that you work on for
three years kind of thing anyway that uh
of course some journalists do do that
and they do that masterfully and that's
the best of Journalism but I think a lot
of the times when the questions are as
you said uh out of touch with the
society that person that person is
leading it's because the interviewer
hasn't taken the time and I understand
you can't be an expert on every subject
but you can do what you do right you
read my book to prepare for this you
look things up you had a sense of the
person you're talking to and you put the
time in to do that this is what I always
tell my students right the secret to
success in anything is outworking other
people be more prepared right what you
show it's like an iceberg it's the tip
of the iceberg right is what what people
see it's all the work that goes on below
the surface and if you work hard enough
which I aspire to do at the end of the
day just like an animal farm you'll be
like the horse boxer and slaughtered
unjustly by those that are much more
powerful than you because you'll be
happy when you're slaughtered you have
lived for the right ideal and history
will remember you fondly